hello everyone David and Karen of film
courage here on a line with Jay Duplass
part of the duplass brothers known for
Cyrus Baghead puffy chair and much more
and he's here to talk to us about his
Kickstarter campaign for his documentary
Kevin so welcome Jay yeah thank you for
joining us thank you thanks for having
me I'm psyched to be doing it thank you
for being um no Jay where we want to
start is we want to start start with
this subject matter of the film Kevin
Gant you say that he's sort of your hero
from your college days what wit what is
it about him what would make some your
hero um I think just you know it's
impossible to describe what it is about
him because he's extremely unique and
you know for me it really comes down to
he's the most inspired person that I've
ever met I mean and you know the fact
that he's an artist just takes it took a
whole other level but you know he has
kind of been definable and that's what
excites me about him you know he's like
a singer/songwriter formatted guy where
he plays an acoustic guitar you know and
he'll to tell stories and sing songs but
you know he he's built like a
weightlifter he looks like oj simpson he
sings about like really spiritual and
cosmic things he's just kind of you
can't and you know he has like a soul
singer voice but he has like flamenco
guitar influences so you know it's kind
of one of those things where what's
really special and amazing about him
also makes it tough to bark at him and
you know that's just those are the types
of people that generally capture my
heart did you have a direct relationship
with him years back or was it more from
afar were you just a fan that saw him
play or did you actually speak with him
on a weekly basis I was totally a fan
from afar he I had bought tapes from him
directly but I mean I was really just
you know an 18 19 year-old kid totally
in all of this guy and just you know
just kind of just you know saw him is
like a god you know even though it was
he certainly would have talked to me or
hung out with
but you know for me I was so awestruck
that I really just went and washed in as
much as I could and just sort of like
you know took it in you know I wonder
ago along those lines how large of a
following did you have during those days
you know it's hard to quantify I think
you know the ones of us who talked about
it the way we describe it is if you
liked him you loved him like he didn't
appeal to everyone but you know I would
say you know they were probably two or
two or three hundred people in Austin
who really liked him and left him i
should say and those people were not
necessary usually a lot of musicians a
lot of artists for instance Jeff Buckley
would request that Kevin open up for him
when he came to town he was just one of
those musicians musicians so it was I
don't know there was definitely
something really special and eccentric
about it and on john august blog a
couple weeks ago he did a great
interview where he discussed the project
and you said you know it's great being
in the studio system now but you kind of
had this like existential thing you were
wrestling with and wanted to have some
meaning in your work and you were at a
point in your life where you're doing
maybe some soul-searching and you felt
that you need to step up your search for
Kevin I guess he'd been disappeared you
know we've been gone for a little while
from your life so what was it at that
time that you felt that you needed to
look for Kevin well yeah Kevin had
disappeared in 1995 and nobody really
knew what happened to him or what was
going on and I had always kind of
tracked and hoped that you know i would
i would even when I didn't live in
Austin I would like kind of Google and
scour the musicians um you know listings
just to see if he would ever show up
again and I think it was you know a few
years ago it was you know a point in my
career and I point my life work yeah I
really needed to connect an hour and I
wanted to just reconnect with something
very inspired from from my own past and
that honestly was Kevin and it was also
you know when I was a kid and I was
watching him
my brother and I were musicians it's
time and week we had always thought like
oh my god this guy's so great our music
is actually way more mainstream maybe we
can get popular and then have Kevin open
up for us and we can be a platform for
like launching this guy you know and
that never really happened but I don't
know I started to realize well I'm a
filmmaker now that people know and
people pay attention to this might be my
chance and my platform to do it so um it
was definitely like sort of like a
cosmic universal spinning thing that you
know got me going you know Jay this is a
story that I could relate to because I
have a close friend of mine his name is
kyler homes I like to call him Showtime
and he's someone that I spent a year
work back in 1998 1999 yeah just the guy
I know that you know and since then he
just hasn't appeared anywhere in the
internet like and I've lost contact with
them and he sort of been on in my life
now for about a decade in your case with
Kevin you know here you are you're going
out you want to find this guy but at the
same time why did it have to be a film
why did you feel like you know what I
want to document this journey um that's
a really good question i mean i would
say that first of all um i would
probably be doing a lot more
documentaries in my life if they didn't
completely make you broke it is
definitely a money losing proposition um
so that it's something that that's part
of a reconnection for me you know our
narrative work is very realism based and
we use a lot of real people in our films
and you know that's a big part of what
we do and it's based on real events and
real things that have happened to people
that we know and and you know events in
our own lives so that's something that
I've always loved to do I guess the
second reason we'd be providing that
platform for Kevin and you know sort of
release you know sort of presenting him
to the world like i like i always wanted
to do so yeah it was it was um I don't
know it's it's it's hard to describe
because I I for me it was like a life
expiry
reigns first in a movie second but I
always had it in the back of my mind
like I think I think Kevin this will be
really good for Kevin I think this will
be really good for me too because you
know very specifically with the
documentary this small you know the
entire crew was me that was it you know
it was me going to find him connecting
with him we went on a journey together I
followed him and literally the art was
unfolding right there in front of my
eyes and there you know it really took
all of the the intellectualism out of
the filmmaking process you know there
were no meetings to be had there were no
discussion to be had things were
happening and I and I had to have the
camera on and record it live and it was
definitely a very beautiful sort of like
artistic process that you know you know
it it felt great it was it was it was
exactly the kind of departure from the
studio world that I was needing and then
when I went back and made another studio
film I was excited to have all that
support so it it definitely provided
sort of the balance in my life you can
you paint a picture of sort of those
early days where you know your sort of
diving anymore so you know what I'm
really committed to finding where this
guy is and then saying you know what I'm
going to turn on these cameras can you
just sort of paint the picture of the
early days what that was like for you
when i first started really looking for
idea what we'd like once you're looking
for but then once you decided to
actually turn on the camera and start
and start filming it sorry yeah I mean I
basically um you know I started talking
to a lot of friends about it and you
know they recommended that you know as
painful or as as uncomfortable as it
might be you want that camera to be
rolling very very early on you want it
to be rolling honestly when you when you
knock on that door and I didn't go that
far with it because I really just wanted
to check in with him and reconnect with
him but uh you know probably within a 20
minutes of him opening his front door
and me connecting with him and just kind
of checking and making sure he was
comfortable with everything i rolled
camera and I just started asking him all
the questions that I ever want
ask him and you know luckily he was
thrilled to have someone asking those
questions because he thought you know he
thought that he had disappeared into
obscurity um you know as far as all his
fans had had were concerned it you know
there wasn't just his own choice he
figured it was it was mutual and when he
realized that you know I did remember
and that I was actually really you know
very interested about it it it meant a
lot to him and when did you learn about
Kickstarter I didn't learn about
Kickstarter I heard some murmurs about
it but I didn't pay that much attention
to it but I have some younger guys who
are helping me make this film who are
you know um doc hounds and you know they
they uh you know eventually when we
started realizing that oh my god i think
film festivals are becoming kevin's come
back to her i think this is really going
to happen you know and obviously not all
film festivals can pay to you know fly a
musician out and house them you know I
was already quite a bit in the hole on
the film and we needed a lot of money to
kind of support his tour so they
suggested it and i went on kickstarter
are learning about it and guys there and
they were really excited to have us on
there and i don't know it just seemed
like the right kind of project you know
it's a it's an artistic effort but it's
also somewhat of a humanitarian effort
also so you literally just learning
about Kickstarter I guess just within
the past you once then you know yeah
yeah okay and then how much how much
research did you do you know sort of
like studying other campaigns or
learning more about this platform book
before deciding you know what I'm
actually I'm gonna go for this with this
film to try to see if we can do this for
Kevin we did a ton of research we
basically you know just kind of talked
to the the creators of Kickstarter and
also did our own research and kind of
collated the 15 critical things that you
need to do and we did them all you know
um made a video you know have kept in
contact with people
you know and and beyond that our giving
prizes that we feel like are pretty good
deals like our $25 prize is actually a
signed CD from Kevin and a signed DVD of
the film Kevin for me so it's basically
as good if that better than retail value
for what you're investing in and
crowdfunding has always been something
that's used by up-and-coming filmmakers
or content creators not someone with an
established name so yeah sort of the
deciding factor that helped you pull the
trigger so to speak to launch the
campaign yeah I mean for me it you know
I thought about that and I was like wow
there's a lot of people on here who
haven't launched their careers yet you
know I definitely thought about it a lot
of whether it would be right or ethical
to go into the Kickstarter were made
some money and you know I the way that I
figured it is you know my main goal with
this film is to launch Kevin into the
world and in a lot of ways I see this is
kevin's kickstarter campaign it's just
on my platform i think a lot more people
if kevin had made his own Kickstarter
page to launch his tour I think he would
have infinitely less money than since I
made that page in order to do it because
people know who I am and they're going
to come to this and they're gonna you
know learn about him because that's
really my goal is not only to is to get
Kevin into the world and to get his
comeback tour going but you know to
support him and doing that to raise some
funds for him to do that and also to get
his music and the DVD out into the world
and it's weird because Kickstarter is
like a triple win on all of those levels
so yeah and that and the fact that you
know the documentary was itself alone
was was pretty expensive and you know it
it's it's almost impossible to turn a
profit on a documentary these days so I
decided to go forth with it as someone
who has seen a good deal of success with
your previous work and as you just
mentioned a moment ago you know people
who do know you by name now has there
been any
sort of backlash with this Kickstarter
campaign I haven't noticed any at all I
mean you know I was worried about I was
worried about all kinds of potential
backlash for the movie I mean in
particular even the film itself you know
I'm very involved in Kevin's life and
I'm very involved in his story and in
sort of hit him coming back to music and
you know essentially breaking the rules
of the objective documentary filmmaker
but I'm actually experienced the
opposite on in both scenarios and film
festivals people just psyched that I'm
helping kevin and doing this thing when
they see the film they see that it
obviously comes from you know a really
pure place and are really supportive
loving place and as far as Kickstarter
goes up ahead a lot I've just gotten a
lot of thumbs up and a lot of you know
you know ! saying I'm really glad that
you're on here you know you know raising
awareness for kickstarter and and you
know sort of uh validating it in some
way i don't know if that's really true
or not but you know to me and this kind
of even further completes the previous
question is is a you know I i love my
studio filmmaking career but I need more
than that and I I do want to make a lot
of smaller weirder more specific and
maybe even some humanitarian films and I
think those films are not going to fit
in the very narrow distribution
pipelines that you know a world is set
up right now so to me kickstart is a
really exciting way for me to do
different kinds of work and not lose a
ton of money while I'm doing it I'm
still going to lose a little bit of
money but with Kickstarter it can raise
more awareness about it and also you
know support those kinds of works a
little bit too how hard are you working
behind the scenes I mean how
are you going out and making people
aware of the project I don't think that
you're on Twitter or Facebook and you
know how are you spreading the word
about it you know it's interesting yeah
I've never been I'm just not a computer
guy oh you know so I don't have a
facebook account I don't have a twitter
account but I'm realizing the value of
those things now and it's something that
I'm you know seriously considering um
cuz you know general I'm kind of like a
private guy it's about with my kid and
like to keep it that way you know but it
does make me I don't know it being on
Kickstarter being in direct contact with
the people who care about what I'm doing
has has actually made a big difference
to me it's like it's kind of woken me up
a little bit about like you know where
we're distribution is going and we're
sort of um you know the you know like I
was talking about the platform the
pipelines are so narrow but they're
going to widen up and I think to be in
touch with the people who love your work
is is really important so it's something
that I'm interested in and you know as
far as the way that I've just been going
about it is I've really just been going
through people like through you know you
guys people I've talked to before and
people whose emails I have and just
friends of mine who you know we can
connect me to other people it's been a
very grassroots sort of like having
beers with people in LA just saying hey
I'm trying to get this out into the
world what do you think i can do you
know and since I didn't have a facebook
or twitter account setup I couldn't do
that instantaneous blast right away but
I think in another way you know the fact
that it has gone all through phone calls
and emails and over beers has made it Oh
more special and more you know it's a
very personal project to me it's very
something that just really believe in so
it's personalized it in a way that I
think probably Twitter and Facebook
could help but couldn't help personalize
it in this specific way yeah it seems
like you're getting a lot of real life
support are you finding that there are
backers that you don't know yeah there
are definitely backers that I don't know
it and I was I was curious to you know
whether it would be all friends of mine
this would just be a platform for a way
for them to give me money you know which
I was fine with you know if that would
be the case but yeah there have been a
lot of people that i don't know and the
coolest thing i think is uh the Austin
community has gotten ahold of it a bit
and people who remembered Kevin from
back in the day are getting in touch
with me and with Kevin because of it and
obviously donating and supporting him in
whatever you know small ways that they
can you know can you speak more you know
because you have sort of been
disconnected you know not not being in
direct contact with your supporters and
are not being on facebook not being on
Twitter and here you are launching this
campaign I mean I mean how do you feel
when you see sort of like one backer
come in after another I mean your
campaign is currently you know you have
150 back or so far and then yeah its
continued to increase I mean did you
feel that connection with the people
that are supporting this project yeah I
do it's it's it's really it's moving
honestly it's it's a I don't know it
just um you know especially because it's
connected to something that I feel is I
feel very strongly about a few things
and and one is is Kevin in particular
you know it's just something that's like
close to my heart and who he is and what
he's trying to do because you know and
and the unmarketable t quote-unquote of
Kevin you know so that's moving to me
and then you know just in general
people's willingness to support
something that is a little bit off
kilter and a little bit different and a
you know from what I'm known for that's
something that you know a lot of a lot
of artists don't have the ability to
slide back and forth between different
kinds of mediums and different ways of
doing things and that's just been really
just you know it's really meant a lot to
meet its that people are are there for
me and are supporting me or just kind of
you know um ready to receive this new
thing and just to see what it's all
about because that's one of the things
that you know I was I was sort of like
you know rebelling against or not
rebelling against but just sort of um
dotting into is
is um you know when you make a feature
film even if it's not for a studio there
are some very specific parameters that
you have to hit in order for that thing
to be you know distributed and sent into
people's homes and um I think it's way
you know it's really interesting and
it's it's really exciting to me to just
explore any new avenues for for unique
pieces of art that don't necessarily fit
the exact you know thread and the exact
pipeline that that has already been set
up you know I mean you mentioned that
you just learned the sort of Kickstarter
just a few months ago and here you are
completely diving into this platform
what is this experience been like for
you so far and you down to your final
four days how hard how challenging has
been I mean is this is this kind of what
you expected did you know what you were
getting yourself into I had no idea when
it was getting myself into um you know
it's been a it's been challenging it has
been because you have to constantly you
know really figure out how to get how to
get the messages out there you know like
i'm i'm in austin i'm going to do like a
radio show in austin this week because
i'm going to do a direct a segment for
slacker so you know there's all kinds of
you know weird and you know very
specific ways that I've just been
involved in getting the message out
there but in general I'd say she's been
super positive and super fun to get my
email alerts and people who are
interested in not only uh just you know
dropping in 15 bucks but like throwing
in a message saying like man this guy
looks amazing I can't wait to see this
film or I used to know Kevin in 1993 I
mean it really genuinely and this is no
BS i made it it it it creates a
community and you are directly in touch
with those people and so that's just
something that I had I haven't really
experienced before outside of just going
to film festivals and
doing like screenings you know public
screenings of our movies and just
talking to people outside after it's a
whole new way of doing it's really
exciting and how empowering does that
make you feel as an artist it makes me
it makes me feel really empowered
because I feel like you know of a friend
of mine who has always been you know
busting our butts for not like
collecting email addresses you know he
said you know you could have 50,000
75,000 person address if you had been
collecting email addresses since puffy
chair you know and and you know it
definitely makes me think it's like you
know what yeah if I'm in making a studio
film it doesn't really matter but if I
want to make something a little bit
different I want to make something
special if I want to make something that
you know is only for the people who are
really interested in what we're making
creatively um you know being in touch
with those people directly is really
really important and not only that but
they have the feedback and to hear how
it's affecting that let's talk about a
slightly touchy subject that everybody
who crowd funds may or may not run up
against and that is you reach out to
people maybe people that you know really
well and you get no response yes that
leave you and what's your take on that
oh that that doesn't bother me at all I
you know what I did is uh is you know
send an email to people and basically
just said look this is not really about
kickstart it's not really about this
chunk of money right here what I am
trying to do right now is raise
awareness about this artist in this
person who is 50 years old and who has
been in a hole for 20 years and is
coming back and believe me it's worth it
so I'm just raising awareness about this
human being if you'd like to go on
Kickstarter check it out if you would
like to donate money that'd be great if
you're into it you want to tweet about
it facebook about it that'd be great too
but I'm coming at it from a from a very
long term perspective of just my my
caring about Kevin and my investment and
what that needs to be and I certainly
don't expect people I don't expect
anyone to want to put money into it
unless they are genuinely
spired and excited by it by what they
seem that's why we you know we did a
video and we even cut a trailer and you
know really tried to put a good solid
taste of what Kevin's about so that
people could could could hopefully get
fired up about it but yeah it doesn't it
doesn't bother me at all if people are
not specifically into it and I'm sure to
for Kevin seeing his life up on screen
so many emotions go go through them and
an audience full of people watching um
sort of take part in his whole life
story like that how has this impacted
him um yes it's been beautiful to watch
unfold I mean he he really played his
first gig in 15 years at stuff by
Southwest after the screening ended he
went up and played three songs and he
talked for a while before cuz he was
basically just crying the whole time it
was just you know it was amazing I mean
just to see a kid he saw the film for
the first time um that night and then
had to get up and play three songs and I
was like oh my god what have I done to
this guy no but it went great and you
know people he's really charming and
funny and people laughed and cried and
it was you know it was everything and
more that I that I hoped that it could
be not only for Kevin but but for me and
for everybody in the audience to you
know and also what's been great is you
know we've been sort of putting some
posts out on our facebook page and kevin
has sort of stopped by and he's been
commenting in a we've learned we've
learned a little bit more about them
through those posts oh you know I mean
how has he responded to this campaign
and not just the film but also the sort
of the Kickstarter campaign I mean he is
just the most genuine most thankful
human being in the world and you know he
kind of comes from the same place that I
do he's he's really like a artist in a
cave kind of guy you know so he's he's
learned he's been learning how to
Facebook and Twitter and you know kick
start and all this other stuff and it's
been really fun to watch him do that i
mean there's almost a whole other film
you know to be
may which is like can you teach an old
dog new tricks you know I mean this is a
guy was 50 years old who's just starting
this stuff up and I actually personally
think it's critical to him being able to
go on tour and to build a you know
successful touring career and you know
and whether that really works out
remains to be seen but he's taken to it
really really well he thinks it's super
fun and you know Kevin you know part of
his personal goal is to play his music
for as many people as possible but you
know for him he's a very spiritual
person and is it's underneath all that
music it's really just about connecting
with other human beings and that's
something that he really wasn't doing
hadn't done for for a long time you know
he was kind of working a night shift at
UPS and you know kind of shutting his
life down so he's really been you know
he says in the film he's you know I've
been reborn and that's that's something
that um you know hanging out with him
and just talking to him on like a weekly
basis you feel it it's very palpable you
know that makes me wonder I mean how
does that feel for you you know to have
to have to take sort of your artistry
and shine it on a human being like this
and it's been sort of help you know
transform this guy's life you know you
know you you were reconnecting with
someone that inspired you from the past
and being able to do this I mean what
what range of emotions that you go
through I into everything man I mean
it's just I've cried so many times
making this film and watching it play
and and and laughed and just I don't
know I mean I feel like I feel like the
highest calling that we can do is is to
is to do what we love to do in serves of
other people and I feel like for the
first time this movie achieved that you
know to like a hundred percent and Anna
and just to be completely honest it
feels amazing I mean it feels like um I
am uh you know I'm doing what it is that
I'm supposed to be doing here on earth
you know it's great
we love love to hear that and and I
guess just as we wrap up you know
curious your take on whether we're going
to see more and more recognizable names
get involved with crowdfunding you know
babe based on what you're going through
it would you turn to someone like john c
reilly or Jonah Hill and say you know
what guys you guys have to get involved
with with something like this um it's
interesting i would i would say it's a
very specific thing i think i think you
know those guys have a lot of money so i
don't know what specifically they would
need it for but i do feel like if it was
in service of someone else i think that
that would be a very specific way to do
it you know or if they wanted to do
something that was just so off-kilter
that they couldn't get the funding
anywhere else i think it would be very
interesting to see them go down that
road and i've already recommended it to
a ton of my friends who you know you
know they're you know a ton of my
filmmaker friends would love to be
making you know weird little 38-minute
pieces or you know experimental art and
you know it's just the amount of time
and the amount of money you have to
spend on it and you know that you're
never going to make your money back it
often gets you to a point where you just
decide not to do it and I think if if
Kickstarter can open up some doors and
some avenues and some platforms for
people to make art that wouldn't
otherwise be made simply because the
pipelines are too narrow to put them out
there um I think that's fantastic i
would recommend that to anybody you know
and from this point forward let me bass
from from what you're gathering or
gaining from this campaign or are you
are you going to continue to sort of
outreach to your supporters to your fans
you know to the people supporting this
campaign do you plan to carry that
relationship forward yeah I do I I'm
trying to figure out exactly the breadth
of like how what I want to do with it
because for me it's interesting it's
like um I never got a facebook page
because I didn't
really want to like spy on people I went
to high school with that was like in my
opinion that look like when people were
doing on facebook yeah but to do it and
to be in touch with you know the people
that I'm making art for that's a whole
different meaningful relationship and
something that I'm absolutely totally
interested in exploring so trying to
figure that out right now Johnson very
nice all right well you have four days
left in the campaign yeah okay they tell
me that the last three days are the most
exciting so um I'm doing everything I
can and crossing some fingers and toes
well you know you know we're pulling for
you to I know we want to see this yeah
they want to see the 16 we're looking
forward to seeing this film we're going
to continue to do what we can on our end
too Swift get the word out for you guys
and you know we just want to thank you
for taking a few minutes here to you
know taking some time out to talk to us
about this project thank you guys i mean
this is this is you know all thanks to
you and i look forward to seeing you
guys around again soon all rights great
all right thank you to all right take
care of all right